hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's VR
oh boo its Bonnie and he's closer you're
very clearly closer but I'm not gonna
worry too much about you so next up on
the list of things that I need to do is
I need to do parts and service for body
which means I got a touch Bonnie all
over and I you know I got a fixed body I
don't know why Bonnie's broken and I
don't know why this is my job to do this
but apparently it's my job dude what the
[ __ ] what wait was that always like that
no no about that one okay repair body
grab analyse the pull trigger pull
trigger push buttons make repairs oh
just that easy huh okay alright sure
whatever
alright well [ __ ] girls Oh No it looks
like Bonnie's guitar is out of tune and
must be recalibrated Oh
first we must access his harmonization
module located inside his secondary
throat pipe Oh access the throat pipe
both eyes must first be removed oh you
must be as precise as possible when
removing the eyes from their respective
sockets Oh first firmly grip Bonnie's
left eye and carefully remove it from
its socket
oh are you [ __ ] kidding me
look at this [ __ ] oh my god oh my god oh
my god you are [ __ ] huge I don't know
who's coming across in the video but oh
my God look at your lag what are the
house oh my god you [ __ ] kneecap it's
bigger than my hand your hand okay maybe
we're not that too far off okay maybe
you're big you're big definitely big you
you big boy
Oh a question mark all right left eye oh
[ __ ] okay you're not gonna be mad about
that
hey hey Bonnie what the [ __ ] you gonna
do when I punch your little Bonnie buddy
in the nose you know me please no I you
can't save me you're so stupid through
boink boink boink
oh he's beating me up bleep point point
ha loser don't ya get some of this link
this is why I figure this guy I thought
that was gonna be like a meat grinder or
something who's a dummy now don't blink
or whatever you stay right there
whatever it's good enough okay now that
I've properly psyched myself up to be
scared by you if you even [ __ ] move
for a second outside swear I'm gonna I'm
gonna sock you right in your new who's
gonna get some of this hoodwink yeah you
can tweak up now rip your teeth out one
by one foot the weak alright here we go
oh
follow instruction isn't it okay Bonnie
I'm gonna try this again
you're gonna be nice you're not gonna be
a douche we're gonna get through this
just be his left eye oh ow
his left eye not my left his left eye
his left not my left his your left
[ __ ] eye job deposit the left eye in
the cleaning receptacle on your left my
left okay boy well done now firmly
gripped Bonnie's right eye and carefully
remove it yeah I'm positive right oh and
the cleaning receptacle Bonnie's
faceplate carefully press the two
buttons located on either side of
Bonnie's jaw when done correctly you
should hear two small clicks
you're not moving are you you wouldn't
be moving would you yeah yeah alright
here we go Wow fine they'll have access
to Bonnie's harmonization module press
the blinking button inside Bonnie's
secondary throat pipe to enter
calibration mode I swear to god you are
even worse on the inside and I didn't
know how that would be possible but my
god look at that it sure is okay here we
go
[Music]
Oh something is not right one of those
notes is out of tune yeah you may push
the button again to replay the audio
check press the colored button that
corresponds to the incorrect nose oh
just that easy it's a musical interlude
I know where 20 was press the blinking
button again to verify your work
[Music]
okay great job bonnie is in tune and
ready for his solo right let's close him
up
simply replace both eyes in the same
order that you remove them then close up
the faceplate and we'll call it a day
wait in the same order I removed them
meaning not the reverse order so I gotta
go his left then right
that's his left that's his right you
can't fool me I'm not an idiot okay I'm
not dumb
I'm not oh you've never looked prettier
oh my goodness look at you you are just
the spitting image of a nightmare
oh yes
that concludes your parts and services
task see you next time see you next time
Bonnie
see you next time hey we're doing pretty
good - marionette not as tasty but
pretty good pretty good
all right great hey chica is up next and
that's cool
so I'm looking forward to this grab
release push buttons make repairs easy
yes there have been toast to my
complaints about chicas acrid smell what
sounds like chica has been rummaging
around the kitchen again what remove all
food particles from chicas exterior and
place it in the refuse
been on your right oh my god this is a
normal can of soda exactly cool hey hey
okay
all right bones that's no the box give
me the box
Oh pug I love bugs bugs are good arm
whoa oh it's like an old soda bottle hey
how you doing buddy nothing under you
right you know you don't mind if I eat
do you excuse me Oh oh I can't eat it
why not hey oh oh my god you're you're
adorable you're a toy chica plushie see
that's your big sister she's a little
ugly but we're gonna make her pretty
look don't you kiss I'm doing kiss fix
that be right up all right I guess I
deserved that one
all right remove all the food particles
I get that I respect that
hey that's
oh hello all right one of those whatever
that means it take that excuse you and
just one of these okay not for me then
okay job make sure sheikah is not hiding
any other treats inside her beak to open
her beak carefully press the two buttons
located on the sides of chicas head okay
don't you do nothing has picked up some
unwanted friends to clear the
infestation applied the fazbear
entertainment restaurant-grade Kimmy
spray to chicas exterior under the
hanging canister to activate the
chemists okay yeah yeah
avoid inhaling the chemists brand
exposure to cleaning disinfecting and
the maintenance chemicals may result in
respiratory problems skin or eye
irritation good job now reattach chicas
upper arm hand and cupcake plate okay
okay okay there was bugs out it was
trying to change hands and it work god
damn [ __ ] you alright you piece of [ __ ]
alright that's how it's gonna be you
know first you first up to dive it was
whatever yep [ __ ] there have been
rumours complained about super cheap who
don't even fry that avoid in the back
the chemistry hey
resulting in respiratory problems or eye
irritation now well done there we go oh
no it looks like chica needs another
dose of the chemi spray why not let the
infestation spray be sure to give the
canister button another push as needed
okay great job chica is ready to serve
pizza and we're hugs to the kids again a
complimentary slice of pizza for a job
well done
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
real live robot boo I have a soul I'm
lost all the child who is stuffed into
an apple - oh well you suck all right
going it seems that you may have
inadvertently accessed an unauthorized
does not game please be aware that's
interacting with unofficial game code
can be harmful to you and potentially
damaging to our reputation ah okay
hi um can I help you you've got the
microphone you're trying to point out
this button cuz I know about that button
I don't know what the button does but uh
push the buttons
there yes so there is that I don't know
what that means but I got a notice about
I came in early that morning no one else
was there at least that's what I thought
the supply room was lit I didn't even
notice jeremy standing in the testing
room as i walked past the supply room
was so bright glowing from all the way
down the hall that was it okay great
thanks for the story I still know why
the little helper Bear is here oh no
never mind
helper bear not there anymore we don't
need that helper bear they're doing
goddamn nah not even a little bit okay I
don't know what that button does
I have a funny feeling it makes this
harder so Lucas and doink doink okay
release push button Bay rare all right
come on Freddy you think you can mess
with nuts
ouch like one of our guests left a
personal item on our star attraction
what let's return it to the lost and
found
Oh carefully grab and remove the child's
head from Freddy's mouth why is their
child's hat in your mouth you're so big
I'm at crotch level why why am i at your
crotch level no I have many problems
with everything that's happening here
right and now anything in there I want a
coin for this give me a coin
rah mana freak all right whatever is it
under your god Here I am trying
to be a good boys give me the hat looks
like one of our Freddie's got a pretty
good hold of it give it another firm tug
okay good job now place the Hat in the
lost-and-found bin on your right
okey-dokey while we're at it let's make
sure there isn't anything else stuck
inside access Freddie's chest cavity
grab Freddie's bow tie and pull it
outwards
Freddie's chest cavity is now open Oh
remove the child's watch and place it in
the lost-and-found bah
Oh be careful not to touch any of
Freddie's sensitive wiring all right
okay hey guys I got it
party time okay good job it appears
there is a child's shoe wedged behind
Freddie's music box music box must be
removed before you can access the trash
gently grasp the music box and extract
it from Freddie's chest cavity before
the safety latch descends what sit what
wait what what safety of weight safety
laughs what are you talking about what
are you talking about a safety latch
what see is that the music box
am i are these music boxes is that don't
carefully place the music great job Oh
God oh I am doing nothing except what
you asked
Freddie's good back good job please then
well done
be careful not to talk [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah shoot Tootie's frooties gently
granted carefully placed the music box
on the work table to your left okay
great job to reset the safety latch
press the button located on Freddie's
endoskeleton now remove the child's shoe
and place it in the lost-and-found bin
oh great yeah that's great okay is that
blood or is that wires is that blood or
wires Oh God
my hand doesn't go that far my hand
doesn't go that far my hand just doesn't
go that far apparently died dad come on
oh well done return the music box to
Freddy's chest cavity and we'll call it
a day return the same music box the same
one you didn't say no no you seem to
have mishandled no is not good a
replacement may be found on the work
table
and even this is recommended what fine
and even Isis have and even peace is
recommended and even peace is
recommended is it now is the slow and
even pace recommend [ __ ] clock [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you game ok [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] ok no
you seem to have mishandled Freddy's
music box this is not good a replacement
may be found on the work table a slow
and crisis averted to lose Freddy's
chest cavity press the large black
button on the center of Freddy's feet
you mean boob is nude parts and service
huh your pain will be done accordingly
[Applause]
give him to me and I move on
ok repair foxy let's do this welcome
holy SH minutes ha she has been action
for quite some time
oh oh this series of simple repairs
should return him to full working
condition Oh first carefully pick up and
place Foxy's head on his endoskeleton
why would I do that
I don't want to do that I don't why
would I do it literally anything that
you have for me and tell me to do hey
there we go I do the road to be a
coordinator somewhere
okay all right oh I don't like that
drawer that there is no fun oh hello I'm
do okay
hey how about no you know what actually
I'm not gonna mess with anything that
belongs to you let's just pop you back
Wow Wow Wow very servomotors our
malfunction Oh is recommended that you
keep an eye on foxy at all time what we
will need to place new control fuses and
the exposed receptacles to continue I'm
sorry
Wieters views from drawer number one
that matches Fox's leg receptacle to
avoid bodily harm wait for Foxy's legs
to stop moving before inserting the
control fuse okay good job foxy has
regained control of his legs okay that's
not good minder it is recommended that
you keep an eye on foxy at all times ice
I am oh no oh no it's like a former
employee attempted to repair Fox's chest
motor using an incorrect fuse Oh
carefully remove the incorrect fuse from
Fox's chest and insert it into Fox's of
her arm receptacle how do I do that oh
my god huh okay I'm watching you
yeah okay okay what whoa the remaining
chest fuses are located in drawers
number two and number four okay it's
both fuses to continue okay all right
[Music]
okay this is your chest one I'm in the
interior one I know that okay [ __ ]
you're not so bad you're not so bad oh
why do you have so many fuses it doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make any sense
at all okay okay
Retreat Foxy's I from drawer number
three and Foxy's eyepatch is fully open
place the eye back into his eye socket
okay I'm guessing it's the same color
okay here we go
okay let me just see when
this concludes all your parts and
service tax oh great that's wonderful
that simple huh
did we want pirate Cove reopen oh oh my
god that is horrible
let's just do better hurt you a scream
you couldn't give me something - yeah
now with that attitude you're not oh
I'll kill you dead first
[Music]
maybe not baby
maybe not baby maybe maybe not the
fazbear's virtual experience is a robust
title but it almost never made it to
market the first development team had a
lot of problems made some sloppy
mistakes and was eventually pulled from
the project for that reason we recommend
that you avoid any comments notes or
warnings that may have been left behind
by previous development teams right we
assure you that they are wholly
untrustworthy wholly
alright whatever you say I'm gonna go
listen and make sure for myself I like
making an informed decision about my
life so I'm gonna listen to this weird
tape that I found randomly in the middle
of Jersey complained of nightmares when
he came in this morning lady he wasn't
talking about it like the street was bye
whoa what the [ __ ] you not here we're
talking in Dale's office but it didn't
look like he was given much sympathy
when he came up he went directly back to
the testing room
he doesn't even jump anymore nothing
scares him he just stands there
he's talking to someone sometimes he
rocks from side to side we were told to
leave him alone I knew I was in line to
do the testing next they'd been prepping
me for I guess they knew that Jeremy
would need to be replaced soon yeah
Jeremy would need to be replaced who the
hell do you think you are is my question
to you do you know who I am do you see
this crown on my head do you know what I
will do to you if you even come a little
bit close to me I ripped Freddie apart I
ripped his chest off of his chest and I
will do the same to your Kate and your
ballsack and your ears I'll replace it
all you'll look stupid as hell don't try
me I will murder you okay all right I'm
gonna leave now before I have to make
good on my promises and you know how
about tight okay but promise Oh like you
I'm a ser right now I don't like you
wherever you are
may I suggest that you rename yourself
to a senior bag Oh dick that's all the
time I got there's only two sections
left then repair which other things good
at night tears which is great and then
there's the whole nightmare world of
stuff but let's just go for that for now
and see where we are before we try any
twenty mode of this [ __ ] here so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought in the
comments below check out the other five
nights at Freddy's stuff I have all over
my channel literally everywhere and just
thanks for watching oh sorry thanks for
watching all this stuff will be in the
description leave a like subscribe if
you want more that's always nice ring
that bell cuz that's pretty cool and
just thanks for watching and as always
I'll see you
[Music]